[Music]
how many followers you have on social
media today
is as big if not bigger status symbol
than how much money you have
[Applause]
you got your
i perspective want to be happy don't you
want to be happy
may let's dive in i want to start with
your most recent
endeavor be friends okay so on our side
of the world
nft is still not very clear um can you
give us a brief idea about nfts where do
you see this going with
artists and how can they benefit from it
i think the first thing for everybody
understand is it's really not just about
artists or collectibles this is a very
substantial technology
that has started in art and collectibles
but long term a non-fungible token
which is a digital asset or the
digitalization
of something with an underlining
contract
underneath that digital asset will
impact
home buying will impact ticketing to
events
will impact every contract you can
imagine from a lease
uh to maybe even a wedding certificate i
mean it is a very very very big
technology so
i always tell people it reminds me a lot
of internet
95 97 99 where
people were like oh okay you can search
for things on the internet
many many people in 1996-75
thought the entire thing that the
internet was was basically an
encyclopedia that's it
that is like where people started and
stopped and if this
interview was in 1996 and you would say
in our part of the world this internet
thing
we called it world wide web back then
the world wide web is not as big here
gary explain it
obviously we can all look up information
and i would say
no no no this is much bigger than
information
this is going to be how people buy
things this is people how people are
going to date
this is how people are going to
communicate with each other and
85 of the audience 95 of the audience
would not believe it i believe that
what an nft is is a digital asset i
believe every person that's watching
this right now
will want to own many many many many
digital assets
no different than people want to own
clothes want to own
you know tchotchkes mirrors sneakers
anything physical a baseball people are
going to want to own
a digital version of that now people are
going to say
why why would i want to buy that i could
i could just take a picture of it you
know you could take a picture of a
mercedes-benz
doesn't mean you own it you can take a
picture of the mona lisa doesn't mean
you own it
what i think people are missing about
nfts
is that nfts have already happened they
just have happened
in video games and gaming
and they haven't happened in the real
world and what i mean by that is whether
it's fortnite
whether it's fifa soccer whether it's
mind share
minecraft excuse me whether it's roblox
there are many games
going back a decade whether it was
farmville on facebook
many people at this point have
themselves or
definitely know a child who has bought
something digitally so that they could
have it
inside their digital world in their game
this doesn't take into account even this
which is going to be the next
conversation you know
once people understand what this looks
like and what this is gonna be like
we have a very big advancement and the
reason
the reason i get such a lovely intro
from you saying
forward thinking innovative you know
when i invested
in coin base in 2014
cryptocurrency investing and trading
wasn't as obvious seven years ago as it
is today
so what is an nft it is a digital asset
that is verified that you own it based
on the blockchain
proof of stake proof of work mainly
today built on ethereum
there's other blockchains wax flow
there's good ones
i believe that one day in the next
decade
everybody will have a public wallet
just like a social media account you me
maha and everybody who's watching
will have a digital wallet with an
address
that everybody can see and when people
open click it
in there they will see all of our nfts
some of our
nfts are going to just be collectibles
and art
and things like on the back look look at
the look over your shoulder
look at all those things people people
have things it's what humans do they
collect things they have things
it's what we do we're animals we hoard
go watch an animal
they take a little they take a little
chestnut a leaf
this we co hoard we collect things but
many of our nfts will be functional for
example in my
wallet you will see a jets nft which
will be my
which will represent my season tickets
so it'll be functional
but it will also show you that i'm a
committed season ticket holder to my
team
it may show a ticket a digital ticket to
a concert i went to
for jay-z or the weekend it
it will be a representation of our lives
digitally at scale the same way that for
a teenager
the posters and ticket stubs in their
room and for the same way a grown-up
has art or cars or ju
why do you wear jewelry why do i wear
this hat
humans communicate our world is going
more digital
and when people say to me let's not what
i don't get it
i always say to them do you get a blue
check mark
on instagram does that matter to you and
very quickly they start understanding
that we've been living digital
how many followers you have on social
media today
is as big if not bigger status symbol
than how much money you have
true and that is purely digital
so let me ask you this i get that i get
the idea i've been following me friends
and um i mean i love the way you're
positioning it and v-con
and that's a much bigger conversation
that i'd love to get
to at another time but the question is
how do you create your own nfc
so you can buy but how do you create
your own
currency and basically
well so creating an nft
versus creating a currency are a little
bit different
creating an nft a non-fungible token is
as simple as
making a piece of digital content
and going to a platform
and uploading it and minting it
whether it's on open c or wearable or
many platforms that are out there so
literally that's a
that's a google search away i'll
literally do it right now
while i'm with you how do i
make an nft literally i'm putting this
into google and sure enough
i googled that but that's not my
question the question is like
what do i for example i want to trade
into nfc
and i want to have you have the friends
you create your own original art
so i'm i'm talking from a product
perspective i
you know from a product perspective
you're now asking a question similar to
the
late 90s when i was asked well how do i
build a website
well i'm like well you go this and and
then you would say no no i know that
part but
and then i'm like well i don't know what
do you want to do
you know i wanted to build a website in
1996 to sell wine for my dad's liquor
store
today you know v friends you know if you
listen to my content
over the last decade i've been very
consistent around my fascination around
intellectual property
my belief the whole time was i was gonna
go and buy it
that i was gonna buy nostalgic
intellectual property
right whether it was smurfs or
scooby-doo or a brand
like a like a peanut butter or a sneaker
that's why i did the k-swiss deal years
ago it was a nostalgic
intellectual property once i saw what
nfps really were i said wait a minute
i don't need to go spend millions of
dollars buying something
i can create something two years ago i
even have the filming of this which is
great i'll show it soon
i went down a very aggressive path of
building out toys
to put on people's desks called
workplace
warriors which was me responding to the
hundreds of thousands of dms that i get
a month from people having a bad day at
work and i said you know
a lot of people like to put you know i
walked around my office
and many offices through the years and
people have all sorts of little toys
cha-chas
things at their desk i said you know if
all these things i'm passionate about
empathy kindness
patience accountability all these
characteristics maybe i'll create these
little characters
empathy elephant patient panda and i'll
make uh it'll be a fun business i can do
my own
transformers my own gi joe my own my
little ponies
cabbage patch kids power rangers so i
was very excited about it and i went
down the path
and then i got sidetracked and then
coveted hit and and then
and then here you are so when i in
december and january february when i was
like wait a minute nfts are really here
very on the press for this
i said the only way i know how to learn
when i thought the internet was big i
launched a website
when i thought social media and content
were going to be big i launched wine
library tv and became a personality
i would remember i was 30 years old
before i ever put out a single thing on
the internet
so i didn't grow up aspiring to have a
notoriety or fame or
be known i'm a businessman but i knew
that if i wanted to be great at it
the only way i know how to learn is by
doing
i don't read about push-ups i do
push-ups i don't read about rock
climbing i rock club i don't read about
you know wine i taste it and so i said i
have to do my own
nft otherwise i won't fully understand
and when it came time for me to think
about what i wanted to do which is
different than anybody else
there was two things that emerged one
i've always wanted to make these
characters around
empathy kindness i i don't want gary vee
to be the only vehicle and vessel for me
to talk about the things that i believe
in in the world
and i thought that i could build an
intellectual property and number two
i have always wanted to throw my own
south by southwest
my own major conference and so i tied
the two together because i knew that the
nft projects that were coming out
were only the art and i wanted to show
people that nfts were much bigger than
that because smart contracts could do
things
so i decided to attach a three-year
conference v con
to the nft so not only do you get the
collectible asset
and if i the way i plan on over the next
45 years build this intellectual
property
if it's mickey mouse or if it's bart
simpson or if it's
transformers well that nft be has
tremendous value
but number two it's an asset that people
can come to the conference and then i
layered a third
level bless you baja i i added a third
level
which was access which i really think is
quite scalable for everybody who's
watching
you know i it's only a very small
percentage of my project
but there's also the ability to play
ping pong with me or go to dinner with
me
or have a group dinner with me or or do
face times with me
i wanted to expand on what we've been
seeing from cameo
what you know and i also know that what
roger federer or what mo salah
or what you know the greatest pianist in
the world what she can do is
she would see that and say oh wait a
minute my nft i can make 100 nfts
beautiful piece of art but maybe two of
them are special
and those two come with a one-hour
lesson
on with me and i i think nfts for every
expert
every influencer every personality is an
incredible
revolution that once they understand
what it really is
is going to create fascinating economics
honestly i love the twist and it was
brilliant man do you have anything to
add or
do i had a feeling you wanted to say
something or do i i was sneezing
no i was sneezing but i think i just
think in the middle east too gary like
about because we talked about this when
we talked about launching your project
like if people were to think about
investing in an nft
or why should a brand think about an nft
strategy and when should they think
about it
there's two ways to think about it from
the when i'll go to the second part one
you could be an early mover right now
and you know be a brand in the region
and ride the wave of being one of the
first or one of the
earliest that are strong and get a huge
level of press
and that's one absolutely viable option
we're a progressive brand don't forget
that kind of press
whether you're a soda or a car
brand or whatever that level of press is
often going to lead to
maybe not a sale of more soda or a car
but what definitely will do
is lead to a lot of people that have
interest to work in your organization
i often find that being first or
innovative on new technology
his biggest strategy is more about
recruitment of talent
than it is even about selling products
so that's one way to look at it number
two
what should they do i think they need to
focus on
the the real life what i call off-chain
so on-chain the blockchain is the
physical art so if you're bmw
or if you are you know uh a fast food
company you can do some beautiful art
interpretation of your products and it
can be very cool
neat what have you what i think is far
more interesting
is if dunkin donuts decides to do it
in egypt market you know they could put
out
10 000 cups of coffee or doughnut nfts
very very inexpensively
but there could be five that are gold
the gold cup of coffee and if you buy
that
you get free coffee for your life so now
all of a sudden that token
is special but now here's where i want
everyone to pay very close attention so
let's say you decide to pay a thousand
dollars
in what's equivalent to a thousand
dollars a half an ethereum
for a golden dunkin donuts because you
know you drink coffee every day and
you're like ah
in the course of a year after you use it
let's say
a year goes by and you decide you no
longer like drunken donuts you're a
starbucks person
that token is an asset
so it's not like a membership
it's actually something you own so after
you spend a year
taking advantage of it you then can sell
it
on the open marketplace to somebody else
so what you could really do
if you really pay attention to what i'm
saying is you could experience
things and then turn a profit for
example
there's a token in v friends where you
can come and play tennis with me
for an hour and a half but the token is
valid for two years
my hope and why i did that was whoever
bought that
she or he can play tennis with me we can
have time we can talk business
but then she when they're done with that
can decide do i want to do that again
with gary next year
or do i want to sell this and my hope is
that when that tennis match is on my
vlog
and everybody sees the fomo and oh my
god why didn't i buy that when befriends
was there
that that gives leverage to the person
that bought the token and when that
person resells the token they resell it
for a profit so they've literally made
money and by the way that's how i dream
of it
i dream of playing tennis with novak
djokovic but then reselling the token
and like
this is a very different thing than
winning a charity event
or having a membership card this is
owning
something and i think that's how i think
about it so
it's a very long a very long answer
but what i would say is this
what or how or what should i be thinking
about
when i make an nft the answer is a lot
i'll give you a different answer for a
brand a brand can come out and say
i'm gonna make an nft that's actually
five dollars .000
ethereum why because i want millions of
people to buy it
so that in three years when everybody
has a public wallet
everybody has a burger king nft in it
which is going to be good branding
no different than somebody wearing a
shirt with your logo on it
no different than being so you know
something that works for me is when
people
when you're followed as much as i am
there's a
effect people find new people they click
them they see who they follow and
they're like who's the person
there's a viral loop if you're able to
get five
fifteen a hundred million people to put
an nft into their wallet
and then in a three years everyone's
doing that and looking at each other's
wallet
if you happen to be a brand or a
personality at that point
there's something very valuable there
very very very um
i mean i listen to you all the time but
this really has opened up
many things this is why i
do it longer interviews because as you
know
you know the short clips on social can
only go so deep
having the time to go a little bit more
in depth here
allows for that so thank you for that no
and thank you it
it it helped open up some some thoughts
for me for my brand so thank you so much
i want to move a little bit to
entrepreneurship so the entrepreneurship
scene in egypt is growing exponentially
um and so as a very successful
entrepreneur i wanted to ask you
this it's a simple question but it might
have been asked many times but i really
want to know how you
see it or what you think of it but what
are the businesses that you believe
would have great potential for growth in
the next five years
so i think the number one thing
that i would do if i was talking to
let's say
uh my imaginary
third sibling my youngest sister and she
was 18
and she said what what do you think and
i would say look
if you have a creative bone in your body
becoming someone who can
create content written audio or video
for the internet contextually is the
most
interesting journey to go down because
there will not be a human
nor a business on earth in a decade that
isn't in need of a substantial creative
department of
making not thinking which will always be
needed
making actually the practitioners
you know there was this incredible run a
decade ago
of getting all your children to learn
how to code remember that
everyone's like teach your kids how to
code code academies code schools
which was true however
80 of those kids didn't want to code
weren't good at coding
didn't care about coding their parents
made them what i loved
look look at me i am a human and i have
30 full-time employees in my creative
department and i'm just one person
so you know a lot of people talk about
you know all the jobs that are going to
be lost when we have
you know driverless cars right which
makes sense transportation is still the
biggest employer in america for example
literally people who drive things but i
remind people that
this is what everybody said about
farming when machines came
that that tractors were going to ruin
society
because all these people that worked on
farms were going to be out of jobs
because the tractors were going to put
them out of business
and i always laugh that people don't
look at history for everybody who drives
a truck or is destined to drive a truck
a 19 year old where she or he wants to
drive a truck across the country
one out of every three of those people
like to draw like to write
like to edit video if you know what's
amazing and i don't think people are
seeing it right now we have an entire
generation of 12
to 20 year olds whose entire dream in
life is to be an influencer
literally it is astonishing the number
one global
dream job for people under 20 in the
world
forget about america egypt in the world
is to be an influencer
so what what does that mean that means
you have a lot of 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 year olds
trying to learn how to make content
many of them will realize they
themselves are not destined
to be famous however many of them will
learn
strategy and creative capabilities
to make a video or picture on a tick
tock on a linkedin
on a face written copy in a facebook
group how to make a youtube video
i actually think this is the most
prepared
in the history since vocational skills
were
were at their peak 100 years ago
i believe we are actually now currently
sitting on the most
prepared for their future
that we've ever seen with children
because many of them
will find themselves in creative roles
doing that work for businesses or other
human beings and i think that's amazing
so that's what i would say to everybody
like in the production of making things
what but again when people hear
production they think video
i don't i think production in written
word
audio video memes
right um ar vr
this is you know the creation
of things the appetite
is going to be unprecedented
and every company in the world will
triple and quadruple down
on how much output how much they want to
put out
into the world on a daily basis and that
creates enormous opportunity
which makes me jump to a question that
was like four questions down
but it makes me jump to it which is the
advantage
for content creators because the future
is about content creation
or production as you would say if i may
code so
peop those this young generation those
young minds who are starting their
journey
be it someone who's starting a youtube
channel or who is going to do a podcast
or what any type of content creation and
production what advice
and what tools do they need to assess or
harness
in order to succeed and build the right
audience
the number one tool of success is
storytelling which is purely a talent
that one needs to work on there is no
greater story
there is no greater talent that needs to
be amassed and the ability to tell
a story now i am good at telling stories
through my words
but i'm incredibly incapable in writing
and telling a story i've i'm a five-time
new york times best-selling author
you would laugh if you saw what i did
this weekend this weekend
i spent 10 hours over the weekend
holiday weekend
listening to ragav on my team read back
to me
my own words that i audioed with him
which is my current book because the
only process i have
is audio and verbal to actually
communicate
and i think i've actually written my
best book i really mean that i'm
incredibly
it's crazy to be so deep in this nft
thing right now
because quietly the whole time i've also
been refining
what is absolutely going to be my most
successful book since crush it
because it's it's really a capture of
all the emotional intelligence
that i understand to be true in the
world at the right time and i'm very
excited about it but i was laughing at
myself i said if anybody
saw what i did to write a book
and it's because i believe in what i
just said to you the number one
for my friends everybody's watching if
you can't storytell you can't win
it's not going to be interesting now
that doesn't mean embellish
or like over the top it means
storytelling and there's a million
different ways to do it you could be
like me high energy verbal
you could be like other people some of
the greatest storytellers of all time
are introverted and write it
there's a storytelling that's number one
number two the biggest thing i tell
creators the way the beginning of the
question was structured is
patience is almost always
the missing ingredient from the people
that don't succeed
there is this incredible belief amongst
many
that you just start producing and you go
viral and these amazing things happen
and in six months
it's all amazing when in reality
that happens to
500 people a year 5 000 people a year
for the rest of us me included 18 months
in
to five days a week on wine library tv
almost nobody was watching my show
it takes time it takes time it takes
episodes
it takes effort and i i
what i would say is tenacity
right that matches your ambition one of
the things that drives me crazy
is everybody talks a big game now i'm
gonna be the biggest star on youtube
and then after two months of nobody
watching they give up
and so tenacity to match your ambition
with patience with an understanding of
storytelling which means
not only do you need to know how to
storytell and be self-aware how you
storytell
you also have to be incredibly
respectful to the platform you
distribute on
and need to understand that platform
because the storyteller on youtube is
different than the storyteller and tick
tock
which is different than a storyteller on
linkedin which is different than a
storyteller on twitter
and on a podcast on a video show
on a facebook live and if you don't
understand that you have no chance
okay one last question for our content
creators and then i want to move to
some of the questions we received
because we received a lot of questions
for you
and we don't have a lot of time content
creators again
uh many that are starting up when they
get requests from brands
sometimes they need to pro they accept
to promote a brand or a product that
doesn't work with their values
or where they stand and they take that
so should
again tenacity and patience
should they wait for the long-term value
or take the short-term win to get the
audience and then maybe
focus on their identity
compromising your soul is never the
right strategy
thank you very much okay one
last question before i move to audience
because this is very important
digital agents okay and you have a very
very strong one
what do they do today more than ever it
is harder to run a digital agency than
it has ever been to run an advertising
or a cons
agency so running a modern day agent
quoting you on that so
what does it take to run the right model
of a modern day agency and
really retain clients and build the
right relation
because it's hard very hard um
i think um two things stand out to me
one self-awareness
i'm blown away by how many people start
things within their company that they're
not capable of doing
they're doing it because they think
that's what they should
be doing you like that answer i love
that we were just talking about that
right before the interview
you you have to know you have to know
what you're good at i think one
uh you know i'll give you a great
example i believe that vayner
x vaynermedia would probably be doing
double its revenue double
half a billion if i was willing to sell
television and programmatic banner ads
i just don't like him and then i'm not
passionate
and that's being self-aware not on the
skill set but on the passion
when you do something for money it is
not sustainable
when you do something that you really
are good at or love
and enjoy there's the potential that
money starts to trickle
and so self-awareness number one around
your skill set
for sure but
that what's amazing about that is
selflessness
has to be balanced so two things on that
front why i think
selflessness is the key to building a
great agency
is it comes in two folds one
you have to be self-aware know what you
do but for example if you know that you
love
print like you are incredible a copy
for print only not even for the internet
that's great that you're self-aware but
if you lack the selflessness to know
what the clients want and what the world
wants
and realize look print copywriting is a
vulnerable business because the
consumer's evolving
if you don't have that selflessness and
it's selflessness because you're
fighting against your own passion and
enjoyment you will lose because your
product and service will be outdated
selflessness is even more important on
the next part
which is uh yesterday we had a client
uh fire us this is real those clients
yeah this client's been with us for
almost a decade it's one of our longest
clients
it was very emotional but she was
incredibly she sent me a very beautiful
text
because i didn't make it hard on her
you know when you have this long of a
relationship in business and especially
when you've got to deliver that to me
i had the selflessness and the empathy
and the compassion to know that wasn't
probably a fun conversation for her
she was probably worried about the
long-term ramifications all the things
that
people think about and for me i just
recognize that
you know agency life is casting
the reason we were in that unfortunate
situation is
the person that she brought in recently
to run her department
is not aligned with the way that we see
the world
and and after about a year that became
incredibly obvious
and she the person i spoke to had to
make a decision
in the last three months was it going to
be about
the person she decided to hire to help
her scale her business
or was it going to be around this
long-term relationship with an agency
and unfortunately for us in this
scenario she chose the employee which i
incredibly love and respect because
that's what i do
you know and so you have to be
compassionate to the client
every agency struggles in my opinion i
watch a lot
because they're selfish
they're worried about their business and
what that
oftentimes does is it makes them worry
too much about their own margin which
makes them sell things to
clients that aren't as good for their
business so much of vayner's success
has been complete it's a very subtle
very subtle aspect of our business but
and i i
you know i'm wondering what maha is
thinking because i was just thinking
about some of the combos we've had
through the year like i am obsessed with
what's in it for them and then i'll
figure out me
and i think i think that's a huge factor
very refreshing man tell me because gary
i'm
thinking about like how to bring context
to everyone who's in egypt
and like you know bridging the gap
between what gary's saying and
bringing a little bit of more context to
egypt because it's hard because in egypt
you really want to like
serve your clients and do what they want
and sometimes you have to take clients
that you don't want to take
because either it's a big name it'll
help you get other clients that type of
thing so
just in terms of like running the
digital agency
to that point the earlier question
correct me if i'm wrong
the taking on brands that
are there's a very big difference
between taking on something you're not
overtly passionate about
or excited about versus taking on
something
that goes against your belief system 100
right you know and so to your point i
mean you know i'll be
incredibly transparent outside of the
new york jets
and a couple of projects we did for wwe
you know
i don't know if there's many things
vayner's worked on in 13 years that i'm
incredibly passionate about
but but i also think about the five or
seven very large
checks that we passed on because it
compromised my moral compass or what i
believed in
um but almost everything else fell in
between and i think for all of us that
are watching right what and by the way
you know i really believe this statement
whether egypt or america
or china you know
it's always hard yeah you know business
is hard
you know this this fantasy land that we
created
in culture over the last decade around
entrepreneurship it's been crazy
i i i am completely impacted as a human
being
in a positive way 99 of time
of the rise of the entrepreneur when i
see
actual celebrities think that i'm a
celebrity in their eyes
i laugh every time because i'm like my
god
if you told me 20 years ago that
businessmen were going to be cool
it was the most foreign thought in my
mind
however what the reason i've been so
aggressive over the last five years
around
not everybody should be an entrepreneur
there are many people watching right now
who want to start their own agencies who
should not
yeah who should become number threes or
sevens or twelves
it's a very different year to be an
entrepreneur versus not
and i and i see it both ways you know
i i think about my i think of maha is a
true entrepreneur
right like like some people should be
you know i see it all the time i mean i
remember seven or eight years ago
there's an employee that worked for me
they were there for
two days and i pulled them aside and
like you should
be an entrepreneur and they thought that
i was already trying to push them out
and i was like no no
i'm telling you you should be an
entrepreneur
on the flip side right now this is the
greatest era
ever of fake entrepreneurs everybody
wants to put entrepreneur in their tik
tok
or instagram but most people are playing
entrepreneur on social media they're not
actually entrepreneurs
uh one thing i was going to say may it
just and also to the audience too like
when you think about your agency and
what you know what you're doing to
you know really be valuable in a market
i always think about that value equation
like what am i doing to add value to
them
what is it that i can do to add value to
my audience or my client
is it knowing what's the latest in
esports knowing about
nfts knowing about tick tock you know
bring that value to your customer or to
your client or to your audience
by just making sure you're on top of
what's happening in culture and
marketing so that you can be
really valuable to them so i always
think about that like how can i bring
the most value to gary gary's got
all the followers in the world he can
pick up the phone and talk to anybody
what is it that i'm going to bring to
gary that adds value to him
and i always think about that i'm like i
have to be able to add value in ways
that he either doesn't have time for
that he wasn't thinking about so i want
you guys to think like even when i work
with vips like nageeb or
with gary i'm always thinking what is
the value i'm gonna bring to this
relationship
and what is unique to my skill set and
experience
that can help take us to the next level
in ways that either he didn't
know he needs or wants or didn't think
about or have time to pursue
and and what's important about that i'll
give you a great example between our
relationship
you also have to be a listener back to
selflessness
one thing that maha probably recognized
very early on with me was
i don't like to ask for relationships so
she's so incredible at what she does and
so we started interacting
and i noticed that she was doing
something that i would do
which was she would we'd be at an event
she would see somebody very vip
and she would this is why i loved it so
much she would do what i would do which
she would go to that person be like gary
would love to meet you she'd come to me
and be like they would love to meet you
and
for me it was no but it but it's the
right thing to do
i'm a connector as well so i understood
it but
i had to communicate hey i don't want to
do that
i just it's not what i want to do i i
i'm in a place where
for me it's imperative that it comes to
me
i i really worked with myself for about
a year on this
i'm like is it because i want the
leverage is it because like i
really thought it through and it's
mainly because i
actually am generally uncomfortable with
the ask
i just don't like it i don't like the
flavor of it it's kind of like not
lighting i love onions but some people
don't
it's i don't like the taste and what i
appreciate about maha and what i
appreciate about others and what i want
everybody to listen to
back to having clients or things that
nature is you may have a set of skills
that you know
but if you don't have the ability to
listen and adjust to the reality
of like how do you bring for me the
biggest value is i don't need
maha or anybody else to do a million
things i just need them to play within
the frameworks that work for me because
the second
one doesn't it compromises everything
i'm building and then i don't even i
don't need it i'd rather not have the
upside
because the downside is too great and i
think for all of us i mean that's what i
spend all my time thinking about with
our clients
you know what's their pocket on the flip
side this is where it's an incredible
dance if i did
everything my clients wanted me to do we
wouldn't do things that really
mattered so you've got to find this
incredible balance of
compassion and empathy while
figuring out a way to storytell
different ambitions
the other important thing too gary in
any relationship
you want to give to the other person so
you always
in the value equation like if you you
don't want to ask
you're like what can i do for them
that's your starting point
which is also super different a lot of
other people are like i want i want i
want gary's like i don't want i want to
see
what is it that i can help them with and
what can i do to add value to them
that's the first question is like
what can i help you with and that's
that's another flip of the equation on
when we're approaching relationships or
anything like that
gary isn't thinking about what's in it
for him he's like how can i add value to
that
and let me say something for everybody
to hear this is imperative
giving is a very different word than
manipulating
which is why they're different words in
the dictionary what
i realized subconsciously and probably
in the last five or six years
consciously is
oh i'm actually really good at just
giving
like when i get in the way that maha is
referring to which is
if somebody's 10 times bigger than me
and my starting point is how can i help
you
i'm actually completely not even one
percent
completely in the mindset of i'm gonna
do this and if
nothing good happens for me i have zero
literally
zero expectations that this will lead to
something good
i'm aware that i mean i actually think
karma
is the most practical thing in the world
why wouldn't
if you do nice things for somebody why
wouldn't that have the potential
to be something that returns good to you
but a lot of people and they because a
lot of people try to do this for me hey
gary
i'm gonna do this for you but i can
taste it i can smell it
from a million miles away that they're
not trying to give me anything they're
trying to
give me something i don't want so that
they can ask for something
in an hour or a week yeah
that's a nice instinct yes it is
okay so we've got 13 minutes left
i wanna ask um i mean i'm happy to
continue if you have the time but we've
got 30 minutes left
um so i'm going to ask you a question
that was asked by a student and then i
want to go back to some questions and
come back to
if we have time so it's a bit of a long
question but it's a favorite
hey gary i've been following you for a
year now and you literally changed my
life with your amazing advice and
content
my question is how do you handle
extremely difficult times
sometimes life goes really rough on you
and you just feel helpless
lonely weak how do you do
how do you as garyvee preserve through
such hard times
thank you so much and much love for you
man the ed
a student kenzie thank you um
i'm a very funny person i if this cup
had one drop in it i would be excited
whereas i always said to my dad dad this
cup could be
completely full and i could take one
drop and you would feel that it's empty
and it's because my dad came from a very
pessimistic point of view in a lot of
business situations early on in my
career and i was fascinated by it
because you know i was raised by more or
less my mom because my dad
worked all the time and she i have her
dna and then i was raised by her
so it became my framework what i always
do
when life comes at me hard is i always
think about everything that could be
worse
i i just do i go to very extreme
scenarios i've said this a lot sometimes
people get upset when i say this but
it's my truth
i go into children being sick
i go into parents dying i go into me
dying i just go
into very dark places
perspective pigeon you know i really
believe in that ma like you know i
really
i don't know how not to because it feels
very practical
okay this horrible thing is happening
right i mean some of the most extreme
things
you know like somebody hit me up and
said um
they've been listening to me for a long
time and they had a very tragic event
they had one of their parents die in a
car accident i mean you're talking
top tragic events and they
it really choked me up the email said
that um
that this was earth-shattering
shattering to their life
however you know after the initial shock
and
devastation they started practicing a
little bit of what i talk about
and they basically started saying which
was true
oh my god my other parent could have
been in the car
oh my god my two other siblings could
have been in the car as well
and and and i genuinely believe for many
of us
maybe not for all of us but for me it's
always that
it could have been worse it can be worse
and when you believe that
because it's true almost always
all of a sudden you're grateful for what
you have
versus devastated for what you don't
have which
if you notice i go into a very extreme
family scenarios
which is why in business i laughed at
the idea
of issues you know and
i i could be disappointed you know yeah
yesterday exactly you know
that's a long relationship to that but
you know five minute walk coffee back to
work you know like
you know like you know you just have to
put things in perspective
otherwise otherwise you're very confused
about what life's about and so
professionally
i struggle with getting really depressed
or there's
there's angst there's even anger there's
quick moments but i can't recall the
last time
i was in a 48-hour funk over anything
professionally
it just won't happen it just won't
happen
interesting so it's perspective you're
right let me ask you a little bit about
um your impressions of the middle east
the region i know you've been to dubai
twice with maha
what was that like
um you know it's funny one of the things
that i always think about
when i'm in the middle east is uh
how real the
uh entrepreneurial spirit is
i i have a very weird perspective on
american entrepreneurship
i think it's in a mature state
right i think it's a country that
has had the great luxury of
entrepreneurship
for a very very very long time and i
feel like
it's um because of that in a lot of ways
people take it for granted
and i feel like a lot of reasons that
immigrants tend to do extremely well in
america
is that americans that are in
multi-generational
situations take the game
for granted and so as soon as you
started asking the question and then
once i understood what you're asking
immediately the first thing i thought
what i actually said to myself
was they have fire in their eyes that's
actually what i said
and then i'm just giving you the cleaned
up version or the specific version
i've i've i've been very um
i've enjoyed the spirit
of the individuals in the region
on their sheer ambition because i think
what happens
again what america is such a large
market
you know when you go to other parts of
the world and you're an american
accomplished businessman
97 of the people say to me but gary you
don't get it
sweden is small but gary you don't get
it you know we're cash and carry in this
region but gary you don't get it
there's only 10 million people and what
that means
is for very ambitious entrepreneurs it's
a chip on a shoulder
my place is not big so i can't build
anything too too big
and i actually think that that's not
true
i remind people that spotify was created
in sweden
i remind people you know that soundcloud
was in germany
i remind people i mean you think about
the huge companies in the region
moon many other i can go on and on so i
think that um
the fire uh and just
the other thing that i you know just
really thought about
is uh i really like
the community so i'm i was born in the
soviet union
right so i come from a very hardcore
eastern european
kind of environment i think that there
is a
family friendship dna that i'm very fond
of
in a lot of parts of the world and i
think the middle east in general
obviously there's a
million different subtleties within the
middle east but
the other thing that comes to mind is um
is
no question the the
family environment
he nailed it number two sorry just when
we were in dubai gary in the car was
like
this is a yes culture
yeah you know that people want to do
different things people want to try
things people have that when he said
that entrepreneurial spirit it's like
yes yeah yes and let's do things so i
just want i just remember that
so hopefully we'll see um we'll see gary
in egypt
we'll talk about the travel plans for q4
right
so uh hopefully he'll do the next visit
in the middle east
in cairo and hopefully we'll be able to
connect him with
i mean we didn't even come close to
10 of the questions that were sent to
you well let's let's
let's do we got five more minutes let's
do rapid fire i'll be very tight
go okay how far should i take it when
you say do not care about what other
people say or think
to a place that you couldn't imagine
what
what what literally blocking out
everything else
the only vulnerability to that is using
it
as a band-aid to be delusional and
unkind
as long as you are not delusional and
unkind the answer is you should listen
to nobody
oh interesting what is the only thing i
shouldn't come uh no forget it
if i'm starting in my online marketing
agency what is the best thing to focus
on
to grow my agency to actually have a
skill
to actually have a skill and then scale
off of that skill
whether that's search whether that's
pre-roll youtube whether it's video
whether that's copy
like too many people just want to start
an online agency for the sake of
starting an online agency
what are you actually good at
which brings me to a very important
question how do you jump to
entrepreneurship when you don't have a
pressing idea or any
any innovation or anything to pursue you
just want to start a business
you don't i want to be i want to be a
professional football player
you don't just jump into it because you
want you you will
now if you want to have an experience
you want to just learn and taste fine
but do not
do not expect to be successful when you
do not have a plan
an innovation or an understanding like
you know like why okay what is your take
on marketing a local brand like music or
food etc
that is culturally specific in an
appealing and
in in in an exotic way to an
international audience
um i would probably use tick tock
when when i hear that question you need
to build awareness because it's
something people don't know
and the only place i know that there's
huge virality
without you having a big base right now
is tick-tock and so i would go tick-tock
uh when i let me just that's
distribution as far as content
be authentic to the content let the
content find its audience
that's what tick-tock's very good at i'm
i'm gonna be selfish and ask a personal
question and then go back to the
people's questions
um jets after you buy them what do you
plan to do with your life
after i buy them yeah win a super bowl
i like that
okay so um how can i start investment in
a correct way
um investments
require actual knowledge you know right
now we're living through just like we
lived through the greatest year of fake
entrepreneurs
we're living through the early stages of
fake investors
there's people just buying things on
cryptocurrency stocks
you know reddit which is amazing i love
that people are learning about this
because
making money on your money is a very
healthy very smart strategy
the problem is it's being treated as
cool
not treated as thoughtful and i think
people need to do more homework
i've never put money into something i
don't fully understand
that's a very good answer as all your
other answers okay
gary always does at least 50 hours of
homework like you gotta study
like don't be investing in something you
don't understand
100 and start from the bottom i mean
literally as of
december january of this year i'm
watching youtube videos of what is an
nfp
going through my own journey you know
for me what has always worked is i
understand the human psychology
stronger than a lot of people which
allows me to make assumptions
but you have got to get a basis of
knowledge first
okay so not really hire the experts get
to know it yourself
everybody learns differently i think a
lot of times people pay experts
as a fake way to make themselves feel
good okay
um this is for um school kids
okay they wanted um advice on
self-realization
and um finding passion kids lose um joy
in working on something very quickly i
mean there was this really
complicated question from a student in
school who kept asking about
what do i do how do i not lose interest
and how do i find my passion
and how do i stay interested
by being patient i the reason i'm
obsessed with patients
is i was incredibly not interested in
school
i was a terrible student you know
i just knew that by the time i was 18 or
22
i would be done with it and that i would
have 80 more years of my life
too many kids at 14 15 16 17 become so
impatient
because they have all these other
interests i keep telling them enjoy your
vacation
because if you're really an entrepreneur
or somebody that's ambitious
your school is your last vacation
youtube bachelor what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you